in a world increasingly defined by
digital transformation and the Limitless
potential of the cloud becoming a cloud
developer is the gateway to a world of
innovation scalability and Endless
Possibilities in this video we will
cover what is cloud development Cloud
developer salary and Company's hiring
career Paths of cloud computing engineer
or developer skills and steps to become
a cloud developer but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and press the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn all
right so let's start with the first
topic which is what is cloud development
so Cloud development refers to the
process of creating and deploying
applications software and services using
cloud computing Technologies instead of
running programs on local computer or
servers Cloud development allow
developers to utilize remote servers and
resources provided by Cloud's service
providers this enables developers to
build test and deploy applications more
efficiently and cost effectively Cloud
development offers benefits like
scalability flexibility and
accessibility as developers can access
their projects from anywhere within the
internet connection it also eliminates
the need for managing physical
infrastructure allowing developers to
focus more on coding and Innovation all
right so this was about what is cloud
development now let's understand Cloud
developers salary and Company's hiring
so the average salary for cloud
computing professional in the United
States is $98,000 per year several
prominent companies are actively hiring
in this field including Oracle Amazon
IBM Microsoft Accenture Amazon web
services deoy and Rackspace technology
these companies recognize the growing
importance of cloud technology and are
investing in skilled professionals to
develop and manage their Cloud
infrastructure within the increasing
adoption of cloud computing across
Industries the demand for cloud
developers is expected to continue to
rise all right so this was about Cloud
developer salary and the companies that
are hiring for cloud developers now
let's understand career Paths of cloud
computing engineer so there are several
career paths for cloud computing
engineer or cloud computing developer so
let's discuss some of them first we have
is cloud automation
engineer they design and implements
automated processes and workflows to
optimize cloud infrastructures and
operations now the second path or the
second job role is cloud developer so
Cloud developer develops and deploys
applications and services on cloud
platforms leveraging Cloud native
Technologies and epis the next PATH for
cloud computing developer is cloud
consultant so Cloud consultant provides
expert advice and guidance to the
organizations on cloud adoption
strategies architecture design and best
practices so this was about Cloud
consultant now coming to the next career
path which is cloud data scientist so
cloud data scientists applies data
analysis and machine learning techniques
to extract insights and drive decision
making in cloud-based environments so
this is the role of cloud data
scientists all right so the next career
path or the job role is cloud architect
so a cloud architect designs and
oversees the overall structure and
integration of cloud systems ensuring
scalability security and performance all
right next is cloud administrator so
Cloud administrator manages and
maintains Cloud infrastructures
including provision resources monitoring
and troubleshooting this is the role of
cloud administrator next job role is
that is CIS Ops administrator a CIS offs
that is system operator administrator
handles the day-to-day operation of
cloud systems ensuring availability
performance and security of applications
and services so these are the seven
career Paths of cloud computing
developer or engineer there are various
other career paths as well but we have
covered seven career path in this video
all right so these roles represent
different aspects of cloud computing
ranging from development and
administration to strategic planning and
data analysis each plays a crucial part
in the successful implementation and
maintainance of cloud-based technology
IES so this was about it now moving on
to the next topic which is skills and
steps to become a cloud developer so
first one is cloud platform so Mastery
of at least one of the major cloud
computing platforms such as AWS Azure or
Google Cloud platform that is gcp is the
foundational step for a cloud developer
as it provides the necessary
infrastructure and services to build
deploy and manage cloud-based
applications effectively so first one is
this that is cloud platform next is
application performance and monitoring
so understanding how to optimize
application performance and monitor it
in the cloud is crucial for delivering a
seamless user experience and ensuring
efficient resource utilization so
knowledge of application performance and
monitoring is also very important skill
in becoming a cloud developer next one
is application Security in Cloud so
knowledge of cloud security best
practices is vital to protect sensitive
data and applications from cyber threats
in Cloud environment all right next is
managed services so Proficiency in using
cloud provider manage services allows
developers to leverage the platform's
capabilities effectively and reduce the
operational overhead of managing
infrastructure so this is one of the
most important skill all right now
coming to the next skill which is web
services and apis so competence in
working with web services and apis
enables seamless integration with v
various cloud services and thirdparty
applications enhancing the functionality
of cloud-based applications next skill
is database skills so understanding of
database Management in the cloud is
essential for data storage data
retrieval and scalability which are
fundamentals aspects of cloud
development so knowledge of all these
things is important next is networking
Mastery of cloud networking Concepts
ensures reliable communication between
Cloud resources property data transfer
and robust security configurations so
knowledge of networking is also
important last one is devops so
Proficiency in devops practices and
tools facilitates the automation
continuous integration and continuous
delivery of cloud applications improving
agility and deployment efficiency in
Cloud environment so knowledge of all
these skills is important if you want to
become a cloud developer now let's move
on and understand the steps to become a
cloud developer so after learning the
fundamentals of cloud computing you
should go for earning a
certification so to Kickstart your
journey as a cloud developer you can
earn certification and unlock the future
of cloud computing with simply learns
Cloud architect Masters program this
comprehensive certification course will
elevate your expertise in AWS Microsoft
Azure and Google Cloud platform from the
basics to Mastery discover the
architecture principles and services of
leading Cloud platforms and gain the
ability to design and deploy highly
scalable fault tolerant applications
transform into a sought after AWS and
aure Cloud professional elevate your
career with simply learns Cloud
architect Masters program having a
certification can help you in becoming a
cloud developer next one is build cloud
computing projects so once you have some
knowledge about cloud computing through
the certifications take the initiative
to create your own cloud computing
projects design and Implement
applications or solutions that leverage
the capabilities of cloud platforms
allowing you to apply your skills in the
real world context building your
projects not only enhances your
technical abilities but also showcases
your competence to a potential employers
so after that you can try for
internships seeking internships or
entry-level positions in Cloud related
roles can provide you with exposure to
industry's best practices and real world
Cloud development
scenarios in terms ships offer a
structured learning environment
mentorship and a chance to work on
substantial projects helping you bridge
the gap between theoretical knowledge
and practical expertise this experience
can be invaluable in launching your
career as a proficient Cloud developer
as we wrap up this guide on how to
become a cloud developer remember that
the cloud isn't just a place to store
stuff it's a canvas for your ideas and
platform for your dreams the future is
digital and you are the architect
becoming a cloud developer is all about
embracing the creativity and pushing the
limits of what's possible all right guys
with that we have come to the end of
this video If you like this video on how
to become a cloud developer please give
it a thumbs up I hope it really help you
all thanks for watching stay safe and
keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here